obrigado
um dia o san antonio na merda açoriana
sou um cidadão preocupado com os sons
como nos deixam ser com o que queremos
ser
não conseguimos ser independente está
tua no direito à autodeterminação dos
povos e acredito que os nossos jogos
somos um povo
o assunto sobre o qual não quero falar
hoje não tem importância porque eu sou
independente externa invente esta tem
importância porque a mais 600 anos da
colônia há 50 anos temos uma autonomia
nessa última opção ea e na verdade é que
eu acredito que nós açorianos e nós hoje
podemos ser melhor
podemos no mínimo aspirar a mais nos
açores
somos tão pobres que nos fazem pensar
conheci uma discussão sobre o preço dos
açores sobre projetos de todos os
independentes quais invariavelmente a
discussão começa a reação da pessoa com
quem estou a falar
como é que é possível sermos a
intendente somos tão pobres que vamos
viver como se fosse um se condenadas as
empresas eternamente porque somos pobres
como se houvesse a possibilidade
aspiramos a mais podíamos gastar é que
horas a discutir a definição do que é de
somos pobres ou que é sermos pobres
foi uma decisão coletiva somos mais
pobres que os portugueses somos mais
pobres do que outros
na realidade temos disse que gastamos
nos açores água potável numa quantidade
que dá para a nossa subsistência para a
agricultura agora até para energias
alternativas
temos jan
temos uma terra fértil rica que nos
permite
produzir aquilo que fizemos precisava
fazer subsistência
temos uma temos paz política e social
temos em uma sociedade que se baseia em
fortes relações familiares em uma teia
social adaptada e isso bastaria para que
em comparação com o melhor para os povos
do mundo não fossem os catalogados como
bônus da partida não pobres homens não
pobres
mas a idéia de que somos pobres é uma
constante na cultura açoriana quase
desde o início mas isso é um caso que é
comum também em quase todos os casos de
uma cultura européia
claro que é uma cultura do clue
administrativo e isso não acontece só em
ações que já foram os indígenas onde é
essa
foi imposto aos negros
postado por exemplo a exemplo do brasil
e dos estados unidos em que os indígenas
que exigiram a sua independência am
foram os povos europeus que colonizaram
essas colônias fim da europa vão sofrer
dessa cultura de colunismo extrativo
portanto podemos acrescentar à questão
inicial
somos pobres somos pobres em portugal e
na europa porque na realidade a pergunta
também se pode entender é somos pobres
porque não temos recursos e riquezas
próprias
obs por curso a nossa riqueza e os
nossos recursos estão deslocados para
lisboa bruxelas
na realidade temos uma parte da nossa
riqueza e da nossa economia que é
facilmente mensurável para dar alguns
exemplos por exemplo sabemos que
produzimos cerca de 30 por cento do
leite produzido a nível de portugal
produzimos por exemplo cerca de 60% do
queijo que se produza nível nacional
sabemos que produzimos uma percentagem
significativa das conservas de atum
produzimos chan
thais gomes carne
temos agora nesta pesquisa fica fase uma
uma economia de serviços relacionadas ao
turismo e restauração está dinâmica e
pujante mas jã mas em particular nos
açores temos uma outra riqueza muito a
forma de riqueza à qual temos que nos
área
peço que façam um esforço e visualize o
mapa do norte atlântico
temos a lado temos a europa
do outro lado temos os estados unidos e
alguns aqui no meio estão os sons
na realidade a anteceder esta dessa
realidade
quanto vale para portugal e para a
europa
o fato de que as suas fronteiras acabam
aqui nos açores se ficar aqui nas flores
e não auguro numa praia praia dos velhos
do restelo em portugal
quanto vale para portugal e para a
europa
o fato da nato o fato de estarmos aqui
nesta zona estratégica é danado
enquanto val prostrados unidos por
exemplo o facto da sua fronteira sul da
fronteira defesa seresta que os hoje
daqui para frente só nova york
quanto ao portugal
há o fato de portugal na américa chamada
açores o que quer dizer com isso
existem cerca de 1.5 milhões de cidadãos
portugueses nos estados unidos 65 cento
são povo açoriano são patrimônios hoje
contextual e eu sou hoje em dia pois
algumas seleções só são os senadores
conquistas intelectuais mix atores de
renome internacional de futebol
quando vou para portugal e para a europa
a área da responsabilidade nos açores
busca e salvamento que compõem cerca de
5 milhões de metros quadrados e que
representa cerca de 95% da área da
responsabilidade de portugal enquanto
paulo para portugal e para a europa ea
zona económica exclusiva dos açores
representa cerca de um milhão de metros
quadrados e que é dono e que são de uma
riqueza incalculável
enquanto val esta zona económica
exclusiva que 55 da zona económica
exclusiva de portugal dá a portugal de
ser a maior zona económica exclusiva da
europa ea 11ª zona econômica exclusiva
do mundo quanto volta a portugal
a extensão da plataforma continental nos
açores um valor incalculável calculáveis
e sobre os quais não temos soberania
sobre os quais não temos nenhum poder
denunciava nós sabemos algumas coisas
sabemos por exemplo que cada avião que
passa nos parceiros dos açores que outra
outros valores incalculáveis paga paga
pra que pensar e pagar portugal
sabemos por exemplo que é um respeitado
há pessoas como respeitado professor a
josé filipe pinto socrática que disse
que portugal neste momento só tem três
ativos a língua os açores eo mar e na
realidade o mar é que as concede cerca
de 50 desse mapa tem suas ações
sabemos também que ele começou a jogar
notícias o então secretário de estado do
mar o governo português nuno manuel
pinto abreu disse que o estudo do
governo português calculam que cerca de
200 o montes submarinos nos açores da
plataforma continental nos açores deverá
obter um valor de cerca de 60 mil
milhões anuais na economia portuguesa 60
milhões anuais
é muito dinheiro mas na realidade isso
pra mim é muito importante a nossa
riqueza não desgastar no facto que temos
possibilidades já 60 mil milhões de
euros por ano tirando minérios do ano da
nossa plataforma continental
eu acredito e espero que assim seja que
nossa riqueza está em sermos guardiões
de uma zona do atlântico norte uma área
enorme de uma riqueza imensa de uma
riqueza em parte desconhecida mas que
não vejo ansiedade de apoios em causa os
60 milhões de euros porque há ali uma
riqueza e sobre o qual temos uma
responsabilidade imensa nos açores mas
não só aqui a nossa riqueza não se dá
somente por aquilo que produzimos e
vendemos a nossa riqueza está
principalmente naquilo que somos um
sítio onde estamos e isto que só não sei
que se não estamos tendo o denunciava o
imenso e não se vende mas pode ser
roubado
somos enormes temos uma riqueza imensa
temos uma responsabilidade incalculável
a não podemos aceitar que quis ou não
tinha riqueza que representamos seja
deslocada para para outros centros para
lisboa sobre elas
temos que nos preparar para isso ser
subterrânea e para forma responsável
assumir os visados festa presta riqueza
ainda agora falando com com dois amigos
meus muito preocupados com o que somos e
onde estamos falamos que para isso é
preciso que cada um assuma as suas
responsabilidades como indivíduo
eu como tenista não conseguirei
construíram as suas independentes se eu
pessoalmente não for independente se eu
pessoalmente não assumir as minhas
responsabilidades
portanto este projecto que podem ser os
açores esta riqueza que nós somos
precisa de cada açoriano assuma as suas
responsabilidades
muito obrigado